part of the appeal and getting all these
millions of viewers
is the fact that you're a college
student now we got to keep this going
yeah what are you going to do to keep
this whole thing going we're no longer
college students so that's what I had
this past month I was like I'm having an
identity crisis like no more College
like what am I going to do and then I
was like well that is something that so
many people deal with after graduation
is the unknown the new world like you're
becoming an adult and you don't really
know what's going on and I have a lot of
my friends that work in Corporate
America you know they're in it with me
like they're going to be sharing their
stories and it's just figuring it out
have you sent out resumes or you're like
no why should I send out resumes I've
got a job I really want to start
something of my own right that's the
goal what are you going to start you
already have something I mean I can't I
can't tell you yeah but I don't even
know actually
did you get an apartment for yourself
are you going to leave these four other
girls and get your own place so they're
going to New York and then one of the
girls
um who's staying with me we just signed
our lease in Miami so we'll be staying
I'm really excited do you have
nightmares that this whole situation
could go away
um I mean it could that's always a
possibility right but
I'm always going to be going out and
doing something and traveling and I'm
going to keep sharing my stories I like
doing it it's not it doesn't feel like
work to me so now you graduated no in
two weeks I graduated two weeks that's
it are you gonna are you upset are you
gonna cry I did I cried yesterday I had
my last class and I cried God I cried I
was so happy to get out of college
because I'm just it was so bad I wish
you luck with graduation thank you and
all that you should be the validation
right right she should be the deal Robin
she should be the valedictorian for
God's sake absolutely forget she's
accomplished something in school a lot
of these kids they're uh they're losers
right